do you know all her music don't lie I do
know uh can you sing all of her songs
not to you Ben Affleck is Jennifer
Lopez's biggest fan what can I tell you
we're just having a good time the Oscar
winner chats with Sean Hayes Will Arnett
and his air co-star Jason Bateman on
their podcast smartless and opens up
about his wife and her many many talents
here's this incredible actress and this
incredible performer and then we're
sitting in the car you know and I'm
humming along like I will you know the
radio and then a professional singer
goes aheads and sings along and you kind
of feel like well that's embarrassing
yeah you guys should just zip it of
course JLo is a Bonafide Triple Threat
actress spray him in the eyes
won't work right so many steps dancer
says
thank you
and singer mama
and speaking of Jen's music I do love
her music it's brilliant and I know it
doesn't uh all of it
that makes me so happy not only does Ben
say he knows all Jen's music he can also
say he's a certified music video star
appearing in her classic 2002 smash
Jenny From the Block
[Music]
he also inspired some of her songs too
like 2002's dear Ben
[Music]
the two were dating at the time got
engaged but split in 2004. we were about
to get married it didn't work out it was
my first like adult heartbreak the
couple rekindled their love in 2021
nearly 17 years after calling off their
wedding and now Jen is set to release
her ninth studio album this is me now
the follow-up to 2002's this is me then
which famously featured that sweet track
this is me
[Music]
the new album will include a song titled
dear Ben part 2 which documents the
second act of their love story the same
way this is me then captured a very
special moment in time
this album also did the same thing
captured a very special moment in time
so this is me now wait what songs have
been written about you dear Ben and dear
Ben cartoon about me have been written
by the greatest I'm performer in the
history of the world Jennifer Lopez
she's amazing yeah Ben is Jen's official
height man it's a beautiful moment and
the praise doesn't stop there the convo
turned to Jen's 2022 documentary
halftime I've got so much more I want to
do so much more I want to say
I'm not done
not even close it takes a big man not to
feel inadequate in the face of my wife
Minnie but um but no but she's but you
too you too you've accomplished oh I
don't feel bad about myself it's not
something I'm not low self-esteem I'm
not well I'm fishing a little bit but
nothing no the truth is it's amazing
okay it's official then in Jen just feel
so so right
foreign
[Music]